I saw a video of yours saying that most cancer patients shouldn't eat dairy.
Is that for all cancer patients?
Can we still eat butter?
Well, yes, no, so most cancer patients shouldn't eat dairy.
Why is that?
So I alluded to it, the first question of this call is that dairy stimulates a pathway in your
body called mTOR.
So this mTOR pathway, if it's up-regulated, is going to increase replication rates.
And dairy increases mTOR because dairy has growth factors.
So anything that's going to increase growth, you have to be aware of with cancer.
So dairy isn't the only thing that increases growth.
There are certain nutrients that increase growth, like copper.
So lots of times we'll see cancer patients committed, they're taking a multivitamin
with copper.
Well, copper increases growth.
If cancer patients shouldn't be on copper.
And going back to that one question that I had about NF2 gene, about emitting geoma.
Another thing I should mention on that I just thought of right now, is when you have defects
on tumor suppressor genes, you have to be more careful of another nutritional product,
not to be taking it.
So I don't think any cancer patients, or I think the state of different way, I think every
cancer patient should be careful of their supplements that they're taking.
I don't think they should be taking, in general, I don't think cancer patients would be taking
copper.
And in general, I don't think cancer patients should be taking methyl groups.
So what are methyl groups?
So methyl groups are supplements that have a methyl group of C with three H's.
What is that?
Where would you get that?
In methylcobolomy, so if you're B12 supplement.
So where would you get methylcobolomy?
If you're taking it just a B12 supplement, look at the back of it.
As it say, methylcobolomy, if you have cancer, I don't think you should be taking that.
If you have a supplement that's methylfolate, I don't think you should be taking that either.
And lots of times you'll get that in a multiple, in a multiple, multiple vitamin.
So multiple B complex, it'll be methylcobolomy, methylfolate, or L5 methyl tetrahedral
folate.
That's what it'll be listed on the back.
Why should you avoid that?
Why does it tie to tumor suppressor genes?
Because methyl groups, what are the benefits in their bodies?
They help silence genes.
They help turn genes off.
Well, if you know you have cancer, or you have tumors, and they are tied to tumor suppressor
gene defects possibly, methyl groups will sign.
They'll also silence tumor suppressor genes.
So they'll turn off tumor suppressor genes.
And remember what I said, if you were with me a few minutes ago, is your best way to fight
cancer internally, cellularly, internally, is that when cell, you know, you get something
inside of a cell, you know, a toxin or something, if it, inadvertently damages the DNA, so
the DNA starts to rapidly reproduce, it'll stimulate your tumor suppressor genes, what
your tumor suppressor genes do, is they basically cause the internal, or the inside out, destruction
of the cell.
So they stimulate the intrinsic apoptotic capsaic pathways, as they help the cell die so
that you'd ever get a diagnosis of cancer.
Well, if you're taking a ton of methyl groups, you can silence those genes.
You can turn them off.
So I'm not a fan of that.
I'm also not a fan of just, you know, a lot of people, practitioners that do genetic testing
will look at your MTHFR gene and go, oh, you have a defect on 1298, or you have a double
allele defect on 677.
So we're going to, we have to put you on methyl folate, and we have to put you on methyl
comolamine.
That's just, that's just not good practice.
Now, even if you have a double allele defect on both 677 and 1298, see, you, you, you have
to look at everything else.
If you have other, if you have defects in your biopterate pathway on your serotonin genes,
and you use ethyl, excess methyl groups, you're going to stimulate excess production of serotonin,
which is not good.
It's going to affect you emotionally.
It's going to cause rage and anger issues and all sorts of things.
You have to take a 30,000 view, you know, for view of your genetics when you do genetic
workup, not just, you don't just treat a gene defect.
And certainly, if you have cancer, you have to be more careful in that.
And the only exception of that, you can, you have to look at the patient holistically
in person as homocysteine issues, you might have to give a methyl group syrup here at
time.
It's, it's not just one thing, but certainly if a person has a disorder where they're producing
minigilmas or, you know, fibromas of some kind, and it's because of a gene, a tumor, a
suppressor gene defect, you have to be more careful.
If you have a cancer diagnosis, you have to be more careful of methyl groups.